Speaker 1: over the weekend in Iowa failed,
Former President Donald Trump gave a number
of speeches in different parts of the state
of Iowa, an early state in the primary process
and an important state.
He gave a speech in Urbandale.
He gave a speech in Des Moines.
He gave a speech.
And Grimes and potentially others as well.
Now, I mean, it's almost automatically satirical,
the crowd chanting USA when Trump enters.
You know.
Speaker 2: I want to thank you.
This was a little bit of a surprise for you,
I heard.
Speaker 1: But there you go.
Trump surprising the crowd and the crowd chanting
USA!
One of the claims Trump made during these
events was that we need to bring religion
back into the country.
Now, that may come as a surprise to those
who realize not only has religion not left
the country, we still have religious influence
in government at the state and federal level.
You regularly hear religious arguments made
during civil policy debates when it comes
to abortion or gay marriage or whatever the
case may be.
Many of us are wondering why is there so much
religion given that we're supposed to have
separation of church and state?
Trump says We have to bring religion back.
Speaker 2: And we have to bring religion back
into our country because that's something.
That's something that is, as you know, it's
under it's under attack.
All of us are under attack.
And we we're not going to we're going to win.
We're going to win big.
We're going to win bigger than ever before.
Just yep.
Speaker 1: Bigger than ever before.
We're going to bring religion back.
People wondering where did it go?
It seems to be very front and center.
A hilarious moment.
Fox News dipped in to Trump's speeches at
one point and right when anchor Harris Faulkner
cuts to Trump in Urbandale, Iowa, Trump is
defending the January six rioters.
This is always a risk.
If you cut into a live Trump speech, he could
be defending anyone.
And in this particular case, Fox goes over
and Trump is defending the rioters.
Speaker 3: Trump is speaking at the West Side
conservative breakfast in Urbandale, Iowa,
right now.
Let's watch.
Speaker 2: These people.
And then you look at what they've done to
the January six people.
They've destroyed them and destroyed their
lives.
And a lot of them didn't even go into the
park.
It was a disgrace what's going on.
That is it.
Speaker 1: Whoops, let's cut away disgrace.
Speaker 2: That's that's going to go down
in history, ultimately.
And Ashli Babbitt was killed, shot by, in
my opinion, a rogue cop.
He had no business doing that.
He shot her, shot unarmed.
And actually people say she was trying to
hold back the people that were pushing her.
Right.
Speaker 1: She was a good Samaritan there.
I mean, of course, the investigation into
that shooting didn't find any of that evidence.
But she was a good Samaritan.
Suddenly the officer was in the wrong say.
They always defend the police people.
Speaker 2: Ashli Babbitt was the one that
was killed.
She was the one that was killed.
And they like to say five people, that the
truth is and they will happen to be somebody
else.
Also in addition to Ashley.
But Ashley Babbitt was a big supporter of
everybody in this room.
And there you go.
By every account, she is an incredible person
and a great patriot.
And he shot her like just like he had no problem.
And then.
Speaker 1: Yeah, so not exactly the best moment
for Fox News to carry Trump's speech.
Trump then complained Many people who use
the term woke can't define it.
Now, I want you to remember this moment because
we're going to get back to that a little bit
later on.
Speaker 2: Very big on school choice.
Can you imagine?
We even have to talk about parental controls
and having parents basically having parents
get involved.
We have school systems that don't even want
to talk to the parents about their children.
And you talk about changing gender and things
where the child can make a choice and the
child can be unbelievably young.
The country has gotten sick, it's gotten sick.
And I don't like the term work because I hear
work, work, work.
You know, it's like it's a term that gives
half the people can't even define it.
They don't know what it is.
Right.
But you look at these things like women getting,
you know, competed with with, you know, men
that were men.
Speaker 1: He barely is able to keep the sentence
going.
Speaker 2: And our men and they're out there
swimming and setting records.
You see the records that are being broken,
records that lasted for 19 years of being
broken by, you know, 30 seconds.
They're trying to win by a 16th of a second,
four in swimming on one of the events, a 16th
of a second.
They're trying to win four years.
And a guy comes along and breaks the record
by, you know, numbers that will never be broken.
Speaker 1: All right.
So you get it.
Just overt transphobia, confusion and disorientation.
There someone and this was kind of a funny
moment, someone in the crowd praised the governor
of Iowa, Kim Reynolds.
And Trump is just so insecure that he immediately
has to say, hey, hey, hey, It was thanks to
me that she won.
Speaker 2: And they ought to look at his past
record, by the way.
Take a look at his past record.
Thank you for.
Speaker 4: Giving us Governor Kim Reynolds
for governor of.
Speaker 2: Iowa.
I like you.
And I hate to say it without me.
You know, she was not going to win.
You know that, right?
I gave you a couple of them.
Without me, they wouldn't have won.
Speaker 1: But it's me.
Me, me.
It can't just be praise for someone else who's
doing a good job.
And then lastly here, someone in the crowd
asks Trump, Hey, when you become president,
day one, you know this growing list of day
one promises that are never done.
What are you going to do to bring back respect
for law enforcement in this country?
Speaker 2: The Mueller report, the fake dossier?
How about the dossier which was written up
by the Democrats, all fake stuff and a disgusting
thing.
And I had to go through a long time.
And still we did more than just about any
president in history with all of that stuff
on my shoulders.
They tell me, Oh, I was a Russian agent, I
was a Russian agent.
I used to say at first I thought they were
kidding when I heard that.
I said, you know, that's sort of funny.
I didn't know what the hell.
I hadn't even spoken to anybody in Russia.
You know, they went through 5 million phone
calls and I didn't make one call to Russia.
That was a little bit bad.
But they didn't announce that.
They didn't talk about that.
Speaker 1: Totally unintelligible word salad.
When asked about respect for law enforcement.
Speaker 2: We have a very, very corrupt system.
And it's got to be and we need from the top,
we need great people.
We need heads of the FBI, We need heads of
the the top people at the Department of Justice.
This is there you go.
Speaker 1: So unable to answer even a single
question.
And now we go to maybe the most interesting
moment from all of Trump's Iowa speeches.